this morning cases of covid-19 are on
the rise in all 50 states for the first
time since January unvaccinated
Americans account for most of the
increases Nationwide but so-called
breakthrough cases among vaccinated
people are increasingly common as the
Delta variance spreads there's also
confusion about booster shots and
whether fully vaccinated Americans
should get a third shot this comes after
some conflicting reporting from Pfizer
and the CDC over if and when Americans
might need another dose CBS News medical
contributor Dr David Aegis joins us
David good morning why these conflicting
messages about booster shots
well I think you know there's no
question that Pfizer did the right thing
which was submitting the booster for FDA
approval because it'll take time to do
that and it will be ready when we need
it there's a population in the United
States that will require a booster but
at the present time no one requires a
booster and we can know that by looking
at the hospitalization rate across the
country of people who have been
vaccinated and it is remarkably low
they're not getting serious infection
all right what do we know at this point
David about how long immunity lasts
so what we know is there's some antibody
studies showing that in about six months
antibodies start to fall but antibodies
are a tiny piece of the puzzle the T
cells are the key part in making the
vaccine give you an ability to protect
you from the virus so my gut is we're
going to see the elderly people with
medical conditions you know toward the
end of the year beginning of next year
will need boosters in Israel they
started to give boosters to people who
were immune suppressed on chemotherapy
HIV autoimmune diseases and only them
and so people with immune issues earlier
elderly next and we'll see after that
Dr I guess it's Vlad you know we've been
seeing more of these breakthrough cases
I know a lot of them are anecdotal but
people who've been vaccinated getting
sick with covid-19 and you know in some
cases pretty sick not enough to go to
the hospital but still sick enough to be
at home
um what do you make of that and how
concerned should we be
hi Vlad
um you know there's no question these
vaccines work they're protecting most
people on exposure from getting
symptomatic from covet 19. but there's a
significant portion that gets mild
symptoms some of them more serious but
most very few get actually get
hospitalized so what happens right this
Delta variant is remarkably infectious
and it makes you much sicker than the
other variants we think now and so
because of that we're really saying is
that our Behavior has to change what you
could have done and not gotten the virus
with the last variant is not true with
Delta variant this is a new virus that
is behaving remarkably different so
let's talk about where you are David in
Los Angeles Los Angeles County now says
you have to wear a mask whether you're
vaccinated or not and some people say
that's sending a conflicting message
because for those of us who have been
vaccinated and that's all of us at this
table certainly you'd like to think that
you're protected that's why you get a
vaccine so you're protected against and
the people that are not so why do we now
have to wear a mask it's causing people
are very confused
no question about it I mean public
places you have to wear masks in La as
of Saturday night part of it I think is
that you you know politicians don't want
to say the aggressive thing is saying
we're going to check vaccines before you
walk in like they did at the Springsteen
concert on Broadway and you know by not
knowing who's vaccinated or not we see
what's happening it's going up in every
state in the country because the
behavior is not appropriate right people
who are not vaccinated should be wearing
a mask whenever they go out and they're
not and so the only way around it now in
La you know short of showing vaccine IDs
or immunity passports which they're not
going to do is by saying everyone has to
wear one and I know it is frustrating
and confusing the honor System ain't
working it's just not working yeah the
other question I have now and it should
yeah but it doesn't yeah it doesn't
David I have a question about you know
as the country starts to reopen and more
and more people are making plans to
return to the office in September do you
envision a world where that doesn't
happen where we roll those options back
in September
well my gut is is that what's happening
now is we're going to see a significant
increase in Delta varying across the
country and with this new wave I I do
think it will be one of the last in the
short run and so my hope is they will be
over uh by the end of August and
September and we can go back to schools
and workplaces like everyone planned for
what it really requires is us to
continue vaccinating and really to
follow the mandates of behavior and you
know we're not doing it right now and I
I don't understand it is that you look
around the world every country is
begging for vaccines we haven't more
vaccines you know than we have people
and yet we're not using them it really
doesn't make sense that's one point Dr
Aegis thank you as always my friend
appreciate it